When I was about your age,
now it was back in the early
eighties or there abouts.
Um,
and this is particularly true around 1984,
but it was true before that too.
Um,
you know,
every generation has its worries,
real or imagined.
And the primary worry for people of my
generation was nuclear war and you know,
it was a genuine worry.
Um,
at one point,
many years later,
I went down to Arizona to visit an ICBM,
a decommissioned ICBM
nuclear missile silo and I,
the ICBM intercontinental ballistic
missiles were very large rockets.
Right?
They flew it,
I could fly halfway around the world
and it was deep underground and behind
very,
very thick steel doors.
It was light green,
you know,
that pastel green that everyone
seemed to like the 1950s.
I was like Pastel Green Star Trek console.
That's what it looked like.
And uh,
so we went down,
out in the yard was in the
desert out in the yard.
There was a very,
I would say yes,
magical object,
for lack of a better word.
And that was the nose cone for the IC.
I ICBM and it was quite big,
that big boat out high pointed like the
point of a bullet about three quarters
of inch of an inch thick plastic.
You know what kind of a resin,
and it was designed to melt on reentry.
So that was just sitting there.
So that was fairly
okay
thought provoking,
let's put it that way.
And then we went into the missile silo,
interestingly enough,
appended to the front of it.
It had been decommissioned
under Reagan by the way,
in the front of it,
there was a,
like a museum with artifacts from the
1980s featuring Reagan and Gorbachev
Meeting Multiple Times.
And it was staffed by these southern,
these Americans from the south who were
grandparents age and they were here just
super friendly and you know,
they were happy to be in the museum.
It was like going to visit your,
your grandma's nuclear missile silo.
And so it was jarring,
you know,
because it's obviously a poor tentious
place and yet it was conjoined
with hospitality and welcoming.
It was surreal in that manner.
Anyways,
we went in to the
okay
into the silo and a,
they ran us through a simulated launch.
So imagine a panel like this made out of
metal except twice as long with another
one of these things out the other end,
16 feet across or so
basically 1950s technology
but updated.
And then imagine that what you
had to do to launch it was the,
there was a guy with a key and there
was another guy with a key and if I
remember correctly,
the keys were around their necks,
although I don't think they were
stored around their necks permanently.
But,
and so to launch the missile,
you had to put the key in the lock,
both of you.
That was the safety precautions,
had to be two of you.
Put the key in the lock and hold it for
10 seconds and then a way the missile
goes and it wasn't as big.
The missile wasn't as big as the
rockets that went to the moon,
but it was plenty big.
You know,
the,
the silo itself would have easily been
as wide as this room is and perhaps
larger and many,
many stories tall,
you know,
cause it was nested underground.
So they ran us through a simulated launch,
which was
surreal I would say.
And then they told us that someone asked
and they said the keys were in once.
Now they wouldn't tell us when,
you know,
that would have been during the Cuban
missile crisis because we were that close
and we were close again at other times,
although perhaps not that close.
And there seemed to be another peak of
conflict in 1984 when there was a movie
showed at that time called the day
after,
which at that time garnered more
views than any movie ever had on,
on TV.
And it was a story about the aftermath
of a nuclear war and the people who were
left.
And it was pretty realistic
and pretty frightening.
And it,
it turned out,
as I found out later,
that that movie actually was one of the
things that influenced Ronald Reagan to
put pressure on or
negotiate with the Soviets,
depending on how you look at it.
And so,
well,
and then,
you know,
five years later,
the Soviet Union collapsed.
No one saw that coming.
Um,
and it really didn't collapse
in 1989 in some sense,
you know,
like a huge machine like that.
It doesn't fall apart all like
once it falls apart over time.
And then at some point it just
becomes unsustainable and topples and,
you know,
it's like they lost faith
in their doctrine and,
and,
and for good reason.